here's how my first line starts you
might start slightly differently to mine
and that might be okay depend on how
different your zit have a look at what
I've written I want to have a bunch of
cylinders over here so they're all going
to be in the form PI R squared H PI R
squared H now my H is in this case of
these Delta H tiny things there's my
radius which I've just worked out
through perfect ago this tutorial here's
the pie out the front and of course
because I've got those Delta H edges
those wits that's what's got a prettier
yes so far so good now you'll notice
there's a conspicuous absence from my
first lame right what's missing a new
boundaries right now one of the reasons
I've left them off is because I don't
know where I haven't chosen yet what
boundaries to use i have x boundaries
i've got y boundaries I've got H
boundaries if I want to okay now I have
to make this choice have a think about
which one you would like I've actually
been leading you in a particular
direction with some of the working of
already done clearly I've been trying to
get things in terms of X's ok I've been
trying to change the variable to be in
terms of X and I've also been looking at
this thing and say okay I've got my eye
on that way I can get rid of it when I
need to using this okay so therefore i'm
going to choose x equals 0 to 1 right
that's that's where I'm interested okay
it is possible by the way to do it on H
you'd have to go from 0 up to now how
long does each go this is a this is a
plan for pie portrayal so this is
retreat here so you go from nought to
root 2 and you're going to get a
different integrate as well you can't do
it that way but here the expression is
easy if we don't have to so I'm going to
now say limit as they are interestingly
here right I'm about to convert this
into this yeah so just look at this for
a second if i take limit on both sides
as Delta H approaches 0 can you tell me
what happens to dr appt
it also purchaser it doesn't it it's
just proportional right it's going to
get there a a little bit slower sort of
okay because it all be Richard it'll
always be Richard bigger root two
factors bigger than Delta H so therefore
here I can do a nice neat swap right
when Delta H is approaching zero so is
Delta X I'm doing it now because
everything is about to turn into exit
okay I've got this guy up here which I
already sorted out hi we might as well
swear this guy while we're at it that's
going to be this I will shortly and I'll
have to but I'm just I'm just not quite
ready yet and then this Delta H i'm
going to replace with delta x times root
2 okay okay cool this is good I have
some constants I can take out of this
right have some closets what constants
cannot take out as i write the integral
okay yeah root 2 pi on to which itself
can be simplified to high enroute to i
believe and now i'm ready to actually
integrate this thing okay so i've got x
plus okay now i'm writing the integral
here so what's going to happen in here
well in order to keep this simple I've
already taken out in order to keep this
simple I'm actually going to expand it
in its current form what is why by the
way what is one
not y squared what's why what are you
integrating and where are you
integrating it from let me give you an
idea suppose you put this into there
that's gonna happen what why why does
this suddenly disappear all right all
right because I've got this from that
right so in in effect if you were to
substitute that back in here you're
integrating this line with respect to
this line and unsurprisingly you get
zero okay so not what I want I want
something else for why there's another
expression namely this one right this is
actually the way that got substituted
into our here do you remember that babe
this in fact is a x1 plus B Y 1 plus C
but you kind of got full because there's
more than one x and y flying around this
x1 and y1 do not lie on this line do you
see that that's weird they are on this
line so therefore they obey this rule
makes sense so let's try this again
what's why now of course there is a plus
or minus but in this case I'm only
interested in this um I'm not even
interested in one half I'm only
interested in our quarter of it so just
going to deal with that now you can see
I could put that in right now if I
wanted but boys are going to be a
disaster when I do that and I have to I
can't really avoid doing that so I'm
going to do this while it's in this form
and then I'm going to see if I can take
advantage of that okay so let's have a
go we're not out of the woods yet okay
so you're looking at this and thinking
is it too late to disenroll from
extension to okay it's not that bad it's
not that bad by the way how did I get
this line just be careful and methodical
about it you're multiplying a trinomial
two three terms by a trinomial so you
get three six nine terms out the other
end okay I something the wife first and
then you don't gonna come out one out
then I'm going to show you how it ends
up for me I'm going to suggest I think
I'll end up with less writing than you
do but I don't think it's worth doing a
lot around so you can dream up seem like
three my trio of three terms okay and
when you look at this you've got some
things to help you because you know what
x squared plus y squared is from what we
use to get Y in the first place right so
i can simply substitute that for one
okay and then each of these worse here
yeah is not an easy neat way to get rid
of them you're just going to have to go
with the square root function so this
guy is going to become 2 x square root
of 1 minus x square now that looks
terrible but hold on a second even
extension one you can integrate that all
right look at this for good this is
chain rule isn't it like it's simple
chain rule that's going to be minus 2x
what you differentiate this is fine I
can deal with this it's going to be part
of a mess but a stool you get this guy
you get this guy now extension one you
does win set that right and says what I
do that type remember I'm not finished
yet not yet remember this is not just
any integral what type of integral is
this this is the unit circle on these
boundaries right but an integral a
definite integral is just an area right
from 0 to 1 it's this whole shape right
without the segment cut out of it yeah
it's just PI on for is it too because
it's pi r square but it's only a quarter
of that so in fact even though that
you're like oh no what do I do you don't
integrate it you evaluate it it's a
definite integral okay uh and then so I
this issue there yeah and it is that
plus one I haven't done anything
to deal with it counselor I think about
x 1 it's true that's that's the next
it's about it oh it's neat but it's not
that new okay so let's let's do this
thing okay here's how I'm going to do it
I see that I can also take out a factor
of two while I'm at it right do you see
that because there's two of these guys
to these two these two of these okay so
I'm just going this is giving the last
line that I fit on here but once I take
that back to a two out this is pirate to
ya pirate too okay then i'm going to
write this thing out the bit that I know
so I've got a one plus one that's too oh
sorry that's a one I regard took a
factor to other two like this so I've
got these two they've become one I'm
you've got this guy which now looks like
this I can still into it that's point
I've got a single X and then rather than
continue writing this I want to write
this as a separate integral so i can
show i can just evaluate it yeah so I'm
going to end this integral and using my
properties of definite integrals say
well the integral of a sum is that some
of the integrals so I've got when I got
pie root 2 from not to one of the top
after unit circle okay did I get it
right is there a minus sign minus sign
yeah there we go that's go yep so from
here like I know it sounds a bit funny
but I'm all the hard work is done all
the really hard work is that the
conceptual stock now we're just
integrated I'm just going to skip ahead
and I'm going to show you what I've got
I'll just get with you here so this is
the volume it's
I think of this as f and this is a form
of f dash all right and so I'm just off
by a factor I'm going to increase the
power which is a half up to 30 20 / that
and I'll show you what I
what do you think oh but just wait okay
so the only thing in this integral that
I'm not a hundred percent confident on
is this guy because it's so easy to get
like there's so many things happening
there so what should I do with this am I
missing a my turf is this minus that's
most yeah okay oh I'm just going to
differentiate I'm just going to treasure
it and I'm going to quickly see all of
the things are going to cancer that and
then going to come back here ok so
that's easy to verify now I'm going to
evaluate which believe it art is
actually quite fun let's have a look ok
because these boundaries are so awesome
this is going to come out really simple
x is 1 then this is just 0 in fact it's
0 & 3 and this is oh ok there's the
upper bound take away the lower bound
which is 0 minus a verb and then you've
got closed bracket minus what I do this
is that slice pi squared on 2 root 2
there's no reason to do that I'm going
to I'm going to leave it that much
because I've got a pirate two at the
front so I'm just gonna gonna leave that
guy the way he is yeah that'll be easier
ok i'm almost there so got pirates you
know where to take out of the whole
thing now okay ready what's 1 minus a
half aha uh-huh what's a ha plus a third
in size 56 yeah
yes yes five six and that's everything
from that first integral and then I've
got this one which I already know you
ate it it's minus platform considering
where we came from I think it's not that
bad okay now that was hot of course it
was hard because this like the setup was
hard goodness me like often an oblique
angle this is this is a mess and that's
why we ended up with the difficulties we
had in getting our and getting H and
that's what made this a challenging
question ironically what ended up being
the hardest at the end was just the
algebra do I feel like that was the Hans
pumpkins okay after we got all this
conceptual bits out of the way there's a
million different spots and you saw me
do them we're little numerical
arithmetic errors can creep in okay